the Star Wars series includes some of
the biggest blockbusters of all time due
in no small part to rabid a meticulous
fandom that's followed it through the
years even after a thousand viewings
there are still some things you may have
missed in a galaxy far far away
here are a few hidden details in Star
Wars movies Lucas family cameos George
Lucas resisted the temptation to go
Hitchcock during the original Star Wars
movies and make cameo appearances but he
did allow himself a few indulgences
during the prequels his son and daughter
appear in the prequel trilogy
that's Jett Lucas you've seen the
library in attack of the clones and
again kicking Clone Trooper but when the
Jedi younglings are attacks during
Revenge of the Sith
Lucas himself appears alongside his
daughter Katie in the latter film
playing the blue-skinned baron not low
whiskey papanoida who became a regular
in the animated Clone Wars series and
speaking of cameos Boba Fett unmasked
officially Star Wars fans didn't get
their first look at a helmetless Boba
Fett until the second prequel Attack of
the Clones but the guy who played Fett
in the original films Jeremy Bulloch
actually showed his face in the Empire
Strikes Back when another actor failed
to show up for filming during the shoot
bollocks stepped in to play an imperial
officer who drags lair away while she's
trying to one Luke about Vader's trap in
bespin years later Bullock returned for
another non Fett cameo playing the pilot
who delivers obi-wan Kenobi Bail Organa
and Yoda to Coruscant in Revenge of the
Sith
the Fett legacy doesn't end there
however klutzy stormtrooper DNA hardcore
Star Wars fans know about two
stormtrooper head bum goof up that made
it into the final cut of a new hope
rather than correct the mistake George
Lucas paid tribute to it when he had the
character of Jango Fett whose DNA was
used to create the first Clone Trooper
army whack his head on the door as he
climbed into his ship clone troopers
were eventually phased out for
conscripted stormtroopers but some clone
troopers remained in service guess you
know who this guy's dad was cell block
1-1 3-8 years before embarking on the
Star Wars saga George Lucas made his
big-screen directorial debut with the
1970 sci-fi feature thx 1-1 3-8 it
wasn't a major commercial success so
many viewers initially missed the
significance when Luke Skywalker makes a
reference to the Death Star cell block
1-1 3-8
during a new hope where are you taking
this
thing prisoner transfer from cell block
1-1 3-8
Karelian Freitas cz2 believe that the
Millennium Falcon is on one-of-a-kind
spaceship after all while we saw plenty
of eggs wings and Tie Fighters zipping
through space never got a look at
anything like another Falcon but the
truth is that Han Solo's beloved
freighter which is one of many in the
Corellian YT 1000 line George Lucas
slipped in several of them in the
background during the prequels including
a brief shot of the Falcon herself
spotted ducking a Khorasan long before
Sola claimed ownership that's not the
only hidden detail featuring the fastest
hunk of junk in the galaxy Millennium
Falcon's new dish we don't know much
about what happened to the Millennium
Falcon after it lost its radar dish in
Return of the Jedi that was too close
but it's obvious that someone did a
little repair work along the way the
ship was giving a rectangular
replacement that you can clearly see
during the force awakens
maybe it wasn't still by the same person
who worked on c-3po you probably don't
recognize me because of the red arm
Vader's helmet when Palpatine invites
anakin into his private booth during a
performance of the bubble opera during
revenge of the sith the audience already
knows young jedi will be corrupted into
becoming Darth Vader but to add that
extra little bit of nilly subliminal
foreshadowing George Lucas inserted an
almost imperceptible glimpse of Vader's
helmet into the show some viewers swear
they can hear what sounds like a couple
seconds of Vader breathing way down in
the mix potato asteroids for years
rumors have persisted that the Empire
Strikes Back effects crew annoyed by
George Lucas's almost impossible demands
decided to strike back by using a potato
and a sneaker as asteroids during a
Millennium Falcon chase sequence years
later it was revealed that the potato
story was actually true an in-joke
between workers who developed countless
asteroid designs only to be told that
the yen was salt that liked a certain
starchy food ok toes boil em mash em
stick em Ennis to Skywalker Sound
there's a lot going on in Khorasan
making it easy for Lucas to sneak in the
logo for a Skywalker Sound company
during a brief shot of the city in a
cycle two clones take a look at the blue
circular logo at the top right section
of the screen busted
Ralph McQuarrie's cameo
George Lucas dreamed up the Star Wars
Galaxies the iconic designs that amazed
generations of moviegoers came from
designer Ralph McQuarrie his concept art
introduced a number of key elements to
the series and were instrumental in
Lucas landing a distribution deal with
20th Century Fox Macquarie's presence is
felt throughout the saga but he actually
appears in person during a scene in
Empire Strikes Back he can be briefly
spotted as a rebel officer walking
through the base of Hoth
artoo Katy ping version of r2d2 artoo
Katie was originally a fan community
project designed to help lift the
spirits of Katie Johnson a young Star
Wars enthusiast had been diagnosed with
an inoperable brain tumor dreamed up by
a dad as a way of giving Katie a bit of
comfort during her final days the joy
received the official live-action
feature film debut join the force
awakens making brief appearances during
scenes set on the resistance base I
guess us hope for humanity after all
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what hidden
details and star wars you think are the
coolest oh I like copters I finished
saying up sentence I'm gonna keep that
in because I'm a rebel get it Star Wars
joke I'm gonna go now